All right. So let's think about this. So we have either ordered list or unordered list.
We've got our list L. So let's first think about ordered list.
An ordered list, let's say it goes from smallest to largest.
Inserting a new element into the list and it has to stay ordered now because this is an ordered list
that involves running to the list or possibly jumping around in the list.
We could do what's called binary search to actually find the position
where something needs to go quickly but then actually sticking it into the list
involves copying all of the elements, moving them over, shifting them,
and then sticking the new one in the list.
This inserting into an ordered list is a linear time process.
All right. We have to maintain this sortedness property.
For an unordered list, it's actually quite a bit easier. Well, let's stick with ordered list for a moment.
We're still with an ordered list. What about finding and removing the minimum?
Finding the minimum in this sorted list is really easy. It's right there.
Right in the first spot. So finding it is easy.
And deleting it depending on exactly how we deal with this. We don't want to recopy the whole array.
But if we could sort of just chop off the front and move over a little bit,
then we can actually find and delete the min from an ordered list in constant time.
That's really great--once it's sorted, we can actually find as
many means as we want and it's very, very cheap.
Alright. So now we consider the unordered case.
In the unordered case, inserting into the list is so easy.
We just stick it into the end and just extend the list a little bit. So that's a constant time operation.
But what about finding and removing the min?
Well, this is the problem that we're looking at earlier in the unit
where we have to scan through to find where the mean is.
And to remove it, we have to copy things over to fill in the whole.
That is actually a linear time operation.
We have these kind of two extreme choices that we can make.
We can look at an ordered list where inserting is slow but removing the smallest is easy.
Or we can use an unordered list where inserting is easy and finding and removing the min is hard.
Notice we didn't use the sort of middle ground at all.
What a heap is going to give us is a way of actually both doing inserts
and finding and removing the min in a logarithmic time.